après les troubles de ces derniers jours
blessé par balle et meurtres quartier
prochaine aux terres sainville les avis
sont partagés certains riverains ont
peur et n'osent pas s'adresser à nos
caméras pour les autres le climat de
violence n'est pas propre au quartier
yapaka terres sainville et à
sainte-marie à basse pointe qui à partir
de la violence que voulez-vous fait on
fera tout ce qu'on voudra la violence
elle est installée entre la drogue et
sexe et non vers ce but une réputation
mais a pas changé et puis d'un seul coup
on sait pas ce qui se passe il ya des
cadeaux mais sinon c'est encore ses
touristes et bon sens bien tout le monde
vient visiter des terres sainville on
est bien mais se rassure ce sont les
mairies sont bien ces villes ça fait
peur aux gens j'ai de très bons
souvenirs d'été à seville
quand j'étais petit bien sûr de la
violence mais la violence et d'autres
cas martinique alain pichon tient qu'à
la violence au théâtre ville mais y en a
partout même dans les communes le
sentiment de sécurité aux platines la
réalité pour mesurer l'étendue du fléau
la municipalité a réuni le conseil de
sécurité de prévention de la délinquance
le clspd après confrontation des
statistiques et des échanges sur le
terrain les conclusions révèlent plutôt
une baisse de 8 % de la délinquance
il ya un décalage entre la réalité de ce
qu'on enregistre en terme de délinquance
puis la façon dont on peut le vivre la
population qui a un vrai sentiment
d'insécurité donc la réunion que nous
avons eue avec les services de la mairie
le procureur le recteur a permis
justement de montrer ce décalage entre
le ressenti de la population et la
réalité du terrain
comment rassurer une population qui au
quotidien subi les dérives d'une
jeunesse désoeuvrée la ville de
fort-de-france bas auprès de la
population lancé une vaste campagne de
communication
mais at elle vraiment les moyens de
lutter contre ce fléau